tac ça vous vous êtes vous êtes ou non
mais c'est vrai alors je fais la petite
intro c'est parti you merde
lorsque vous serez vous prêts issus et
martin you to want excuses au joueur
trop compagnie de troyes l'isi bonjour
au salut alors nous avons les juges
medelci et les y est alors en fait on
est actuellement sur allez vous me
suivez je suis maître de fil de menace
super alors on est actuellement sur un
slender multijoueur en quelque sorte
c'est à dire que nous sommes des
plombiers ok on est au milieu d'une
forêt d'accord très bien et on doit
trouver des pages alors même dans des
palais rapport logique entre des pompes
pour une lampe qui fait une magnifique
croire alors on sait pas pourquoi la
langue fait une croix bon c'est génial
et railleries norad dégueulasse
alors c'est vraiment un beau diable bref
le jeu est très légal or il ya aussi un
petit con tour magnifique autour des
arbres bon bref une maison msa ah ouais
bah alors il faut savoir qu'on aime bien
jouer à ce petit [ __ ] y'a plus la page
ci est là bas on aime bien jouer à ce
petit jeu avec les lazy donc c'est le
même système que sneijder là on a une
page sur 11
et cette fois c'est parce länder qui
nous suit dans la forêt tout seul
c'était en fait un zoom et un espèce de
loups garous attends je vais tendre
septembre c'est peut-être un peu trop
froid c'est en fait un loup garou
bah vous allez voir des combats par
contre j'ai remarqué un petit truc dans
la partie d'avancé que moi des fois il
apparaît et il appartient pas pour les
autres
donc ça veut dire que des fois moi je
chie dessus alors que eux ils n'y a rien
d'obscène couvert attendu à part dont je
vous attends
ah vous êtes maintenant c'est la seule
personne de att attentes à quoi tu as un
signe sur ton truc une loi non voilà
alors oui évidemment c'est parti on va
suivre le chemin les mecs
bastide le chat ouais vous suivez là où
quand et où passent entre les arbres
l'on peut pas non et cela on veut ouais
je courais rouge la cellule où la viola
va y aller là bas
maintenant je veux juste montrer aux
gens ce que ça fait ok il est plus là
bas ok bon venez venez venez venez il
était là bas en fait c'est soit on voit
deux petits points rouges sous on voit
comme la n y croient comme ça mais en
rouge et en fait c'est le loup dessus
voilà donc des fois il dit rester paie
donc c'est vraiment comme center sauf
que yahia possibilité de jouer en
multijoueur grâce à la machine
alors je trouvais doit trotter a été
automatiquement thamond qanooni bug bon
ce paravent continu à temps je leur
lance du cmob cep a annoncé que 12 ans
et pas une page là bas c'est pas une
page la barre c'est je crois la cie
venez venez venez à dont on peut se
passer
vous êtes vraiment des gros chiens c'est
bon je sois je conçois la taille des du
tout le monde y en a tant à la loyale et
il ya les trucs là au milieu de ces les
grands pics le maillot photo wenn asie
ah ouais mais là bas c'est des pizzas
des poèmes que j'avais trop peur à west
ham cet effet tous au dos la bad à la
fois je me souviens ouais ouais ouais
bah c'est super non plus
cassez-vous m'a tuer il m'a tuer le
match
attention apparition de squeeze crise au
droit 2-1 au caire eux c'est revoir les
gens on échoue on est au taquet alors
vous êtes tous là on est là ok vous êtes
prêts on suit est cette fois c'est le
font par là bas allez hop c'est parti
allez approprié le meilleur allez hop
moi je danse le jeu just dance on
attendait ces partis tôt mais ce parti
allait aller à fond et je t'en prie je
suis dedans moi pour ce coup-ci il
faudra juste trouver le chemin d'autres
talents faites attention ne pouvez pas
vous arrêter à temps a trop mangé le
schéma est sur le chemin pour kaka c'est
bon alors je me suis dit c'est bon tu
sais que vous en tant que tu es bon tu
nous dis quand c'est bon voilà c'est bon
c'est bon allez c'est parti on pas par
la droite ouah [ __ ] was put un jeu en
fait les jeux est très mal foutu parce
qu'il met plein de trucs qui bonnes fins
et très bien foutu on peut dire mais tu
sais tu vois des trucs briller au loin
je sais jamais si c'est une page s'est
juste l'espace entre deux arbres où le
loup passer mon temps
on cotise woippy taille al oula bayal
ulama demi-tour demi tour de mythos ya
le loup là bas j'avais vu avec ses yeux
elles sont réparés désert j'aimerais y
aurait pu mettre un sac trop menaçant la
gamme mois moi je peux plus courir quand
je peux plus courir je peux plus courir
le mage et eni volante la vase il est
totalement plat c'est quoi ce bordel
gildas volant plat c'était peut-être
quoi il faudrait de loeb au plus tard au
syndic est bien celui qui me suit viens
viens au butin alors tu reviens au
courant playmobil un tailleur
allez venez venez venez en chine
continue et sérieuse a ajouté m
et là je n'arrive supervise il arrive
super vite dont juste incroyable autant
center tu dois petit à petit tu vois si
je vous vois tu vois après celle au
gland caché là un arbre puis comme hugo
âgé la mecque
les gars je vous attends tu as un mec
sympa oui je sois faisait vraiment
longtemps un [ __ ] autant sur sender
les quatre premières passes tu vois tu
es tranquille
aminata une page c'est bon il est là qui
a pris ma page il te sud irak roster et
il te défonces coach et qu'est-ce qui
fait dans cette fois il est aussi dans
la ville
attendez les gars ça fait comme tout à
l'heure on va se faire [ __ ] là je le
sens venez venez way
le match aller pique on va se repérer
par rapport au pic donc l'un au sud à
l'est
enfin je prends le vent vi fait je peux
plus courir attend deux secondes je
regarde comment le vent y souffle
ok on va continuer au niveau du nord
donc par là bas on va aller au nord on
va les honneurs éteignez vos lampes et
nouveau leader
y aller bien gilou43 gala faut que je te
suis on va dans l'épique et hop on
attire mais oui nico nico fait courir et
bat mouraient mouraient je m'en bats les
couilles
j'aime bien les gars je suis perdu ouais
royal ou yalou ya lula venez venez fils
de johnny police c'est pas tout ça au
[ __ ]
venez au milieu des pics rdv milieu
piqueté mdc si si venez venez venez
venez aussi moi tiens tiens que je te
suspect clef à molette jeter suspect
fait un malaise ce métier je suis la clé
je suis c'est la clé à molette attends
je peux plus courir là j'ai plus
marathon commando attend on va s'enfuir
par là bas du coup la viande est hachée
attends je prends le vent ok direction
sud ouest sud ouest
allez c'est parti est et et développe
je vois plus rien n'arrête d'allumer et
alors bordel aveugle à vtt soit aussi en
quoi tu paniques tôt la haye a le bruit
du corbeau à ce moment-là a cédé
magnifique les gens pour en témoigner
tu as fait ta blague de merde ça fait et
jeunes dagen mec que courir sur quoi
vous êtes où vous êtes tous venez venez
ça y'a un truc je pense qu'il ya lula
bye al oula venez venez ok on va aller
au niveau de l'ouest à l'est au niveau
de l'ouest je répète au niveau de
l'ouest
alors si on pouvait au yen pas je la
voyais pas cela va les gars de courir
acheter dubaï sheikh vous me rejoignait
le cas il me semble tous les jours elle
énoncé des fois j'arrête de courir c'est
tout en fait je fais toujours attention
j'aime ça j'ai une page on peut même
faire une petit jeu là on a quatre
visions continue on continue avec
pourquoi il ya un jeu pour l élection si
on a les onze on est juste des bosses je
viens de yanbian d'accueillir mes
courses et occupent leur état mais
arrête de me faire câblée talents comme
ça c'était un sujet là et ça mais c'est
que chaque fois que je perds mes joueurs
je fais les conversions via l'avion il
ya l'avion parce que l'avion l'avion ça
fait lever les yeux au bas ce n'est pas
me faire ça fait lever la queue
chaque banque un bruit de corbeaux sur
est appauvri a vite fait le trou et
regardez pas regardé par regardez pas le
loup regardez regardez à tomber sur la
viande à des enfants n'étaient montées
sur l'avion woippy taille à loupia la
page mais yann loup [ __ ] t'as je suis
bloqué dans un avion mais aussi aux
[ __ ] à moi aussi
comment même dessus commandes montent
dessus taille à lula à l'est du front la
passe et je suis son ami oscar
comment fait il faut voter bien le
milieu il nous dit mieux c'est bon c'est
bon au mode sur l'avion
c'est pour aia le loup en bas j'entends
le loup le renard et les yeux rouges et
jaunes dont on est sûr rouge attend
[ __ ] on glisse sur l'avion non non pas
pourquoi mon perso il marche tout seul
web de fuck
je pense que c'était un bon salon pour
ça un jeu on était venu là bas et je
pense et si le débat monte tout allait
brocade a decade sultan mehmet mon
plombier marche tout seul à l'égaler
gaël nous trois on reste collé je vous
propose qu'on se rassure nos milieux des
piques
non elle vous me suivez ou pas vous
monsieur ou pas à tant que je suis là je
suis moi je suis dit qu'il note là vous
ne suivez ou pas ouais ouais ouais ok
c'est parti c'est parti courez courez
courez courez
courez courez vont être abondamment non
je peux plus basique pas que je vais
mourir
ouais vous retournez pas oui c'est quoi
ça sert un long billet mais [ __ ]
l'enculé je ne pouvais presque dernier
je pète dernier pendant le choc mais
l'appellation fait la médecine et un
talent toi je te regarde mais je suis
mort à l'origine la voix je pète un
ballon des yeux tâche ne songe pas à
l'argent coule à je te dis je le sens
pas là ça sent ça semble où sa voix si
ça semble attend au piège froide wiimote
dans la main tu vois ça mais tu es parti
ou plus mais je sais pas je vous suis
bien je suis là et je suis là où je suis
là les stress à monsieur veilleuse ou
courir à moi non plus et moi non plus la
position foetale contre un arbre
attendant comme ça à 3 à 3,3 en anglais
coup et s'il où il arrive il fait un
trou piraterie plus en cours
vasic non je peux pas je peux pas t'en
gallois taco schoute afpa au cours
concours concours coup pour coup retour
pour course sur hegel vite monsieur
attend ya la petite échelle nom est déjà
venu ici [ __ ] c'est pas grave
owens ou de termites et je suis seul
avec le thé ou med résilience car on
s'en fout et menez lahlou qui a des
liens et boissons avec le plus court est
refusé mon cul
mais si je vous retrouve à monaco
tu peux pas réparer le loup un petit
côté ou thé ou chocolat sont athées ou
non mais on est au milieu de la forêt
nouvelle room à se rediriger vers à
quelque chose de civiliser mais j'ai une
maison où s'est perdue occupe le fbi
melvin rdv au pic du carlit sourire quoi
attend les piques et voit pas là il ya
un peu de ça le regarde le ciel
arrête de courir et que tu t'es cassé je
vois ces bulletins par don balon tiens
je fais je suis bon je suis bête est
morte à vis du timbre de façon à css a
dit que tarder bref allez on continue
oui je bédié car oui j'ai peur oui
l'enregistrement s'est arrêtée alors oui
je le remets le tout dans la grâce à
tous dans la grâce et la beauté
je songe qu'à renflouer des pâtes à
hamar être j'arrive à ce mode a coûté
200 communes ont dû courir là au but
dernière j'ai appelé cinq fois sur shiv
sena faire tourner windows phone
[ __ ] ya le bruit des roues dans le cas
je me suis fait chier dessus je crois
que c'est humain les gars j'ai
accidentellement tiré cinq fois sur la
touche shift parce que je pouvais plus
courir et je pousse à me jeter message
d'avoir et moi j'ai recraché
en tout cas si vous voulez voir un petit
tuto pour jouer à plusieurs sur ce jeu
n'hésitez pas
les reliera paris et maintenant j'ai
fait un petit tuto avec les chocs pour
montrer comment faire et puis voilà en
tout cas bas j'espère que ça vous aura
plu cette petite vidéo combine les
petits lazy ouais je sais moi que j'ai
jamais faite vidéo avec les allez-y
c'est ma team pour ceux qui ne savent
pas c'est une anémie quoi ça fait plus
d'un an et demi qu'on gouverne
enfin bon voilà on fera sûrement des
vidéos sur d'autres trucs même tête un
colosse ensemble enfin je l'annoncerai
bien te fera rien ouais
oh oui et puis voilà on se retrouve
bientôt dans une nouvelle vidéo tuant
tout le monde puisse arrive tous les
jours elle